-Hello and welcome back
to our makeshift studio
in an attic crawl space.
So far, we've migrated
from the hallway to the garage
to the living room to the attic.
And you may be wondering
what's that little door
behind me?
Is it where we keep
our camping gear?
Or is it a door
to another dimension?
And how about that tiny chair?
Is it for my kids,
or is that where
the attic hobbit smokes his pipe
and reminisces about
the Battle of the Five Armies?
I'm sorry to say
I'll never tell.
Now, we're all bracing for
a very difficult few weeks --
or months, but there are things
the federal government
could be doing right now
to help us get through this.
Instead, the president
has essentially
abdicated his responsibility
and left the states
up to themselves.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
A pandemic like this requires
a centralized federal Response.
You know how Republicans always
complain about big government?
Well, how sweet would
a big government be right now?
Because I don't know about you,
but this tiny government stuff
sucks.
It's like being on the top floor
of a burning building,
but instead of a catch net,
the firemen show up
with a little workout
trampoline.
Feels like right now
we've largely been left
to fend for ourselves.
For example, for weeks we were
told that masks don't work
and that we shouldn't wear them.
Now all of a sudden, the CDC
is considering
recommending mask usage
for all Americans.
You might want answers about
what you should be doing
to protect yourself and others
and why the government
is changing its position.
Instead, the best advice the
president could offer on Tuesday
was this --
-You know, you can use a scarf.
A scarf is -- everybody --
a lot of people have scarves.
And you can use a scarf.
A scarf would be very good.
I would say do it.
But use a scarf if you want.
I mean, most people have scarves
and scarves are very good.
-Oh, great. So now the president
is Martha Stewart.
[ As Trump ] Using a blanket,
a bike helmet,
and some Saran wrap, you can
make your own hazmat suit.
Homemade. Pretty great.
[ Normal voice ] But it's true.
Most people do have scarves
and no one has more scarves
than Lenny Kravitz.
So breathe easy, everyone.
Lenny Kravitz is in the clear.
I mean, obviously the man
has been preparing
for this moment his entire life.
I mean, look at that.
Not only can he use that scarf,
he can share it with
two other people
while maintaining
a six-foot difference.
Now, it's true, there is
evidence that wearing a mask
or some other kind of face
covering,
even something rudimentary,
can prevent asymptomatic spread
of the disease.
You can wear a bandanna.
You can wear a cloth.
Just don't be a guy
who wears a Jason mask.
I mean, one, it's freaky,
and two, it literally has holes.
Jason, come on, man, that mask
is not approved by the CDC.
Haven't you killed
enough people, Jason?
Now, the president could have
gone into detail about that
or any other number
of other important issues
during his briefing
on Wednesday, but instead,
he chose to brag about this --
-Did you know I was number one
on Facebook?
I mean, I just found out
I'm number one on Facebook.
I thought that was very nice.
-What the [bleep] are you
talking about, man?
You're in the middle
of a deadly pandemic,
and you're bragging about
how popular you are on Facebook?
First of all, of course
you're popular on Facebook.
It's the preferred method
of communication
of drunk aunts and people
who still own flip phones.
Being number one on Facebook
is like, I don't know,
having the #1 album in Belgium.
I mean, good for you, I guess.
But your album probably sucks.
And by the way,
that's not even true.
You only have 28 million
followers on Facebook.
Barack Obama has 53 million.
I wish someone would point
that out to Trump
because it would annoy the hell
out of him.
He'd force the CDC to update
its coronavirus guidelines.
One, stay home.
Two, wash your hands.
Three, follow Donald Trump
on Facebook,
but stay six feet away
from Barack Obama.
[ As Trump ] We've heard he's
Facebook friends with Tom Hanks.
So his page definitely,
definitely has it now.
[ Normal voice ] The fate
we're currently enduring
and the months of hardship ahead
were not inevitable.
Hundreds of thousands
of people dying,
a national lockdown that
has disrupted daily life --
None of that had to happen.
I mean, just look at countries
that managed
to successfully contain
the crisis --
Countries much closer to China,
the source of the outbreak,
like Taiwan.
-Taiwan is just off the coast
of mainland China.
Millions travel between Taiwan
and the Chinese mainland.
Johns Hopkins University
had predicted that Taiwan
would have the second-most
COVID-19 cases in the world.
But today, there are 80
countries and territories
with more than
Taiwan's 329 cases.
-Taiwan has succeeded at
containing COVID-19
starting at arrival.
The first step Taiwan took
was identifying possible cases.
Lee told authorities she'd had
a cough in the last two weeks.
So security escorted her
to secondary screening.
She had her temperature taken
like this woman,
and she got a COVID-19 test
at the airport.
Taiwan uploads these results
into its national
healthcare database.
After her bags were disinfected,
her ride home was in
a government provided taxi
by herself.
One phone app allows
Taiwan residents
to find stores
with masks in stock.
Another app provides information
on all of those
who are COVID-19 positive,
where they've been,
and their case histories.
-Holy [bleep]
They take your temperature,
give you a test,
disinfect your bags,
give you a ride home,
an app that tells you
where to buy masks,
and you get six months
of Showtime free of charge.
Quarantine yourself
and don't come out
until you've watched
every episode of "Shameless."
That's certainly better than
what our government is doing.
Compare that to when you arrive
at an airport in the U.S.
The closest anyone comes
to taking your temperature
is when a TSA agent gives you
a full cavity search
because you accidentally
packed a bottle of shampoo
that was larger than 3.4 ounces.
Or if you don't want to look
at Taiwan,
take Iceland, another country
that's using advanced strategies
to track and isolate cases
of coronavirus,
including detective work.
-For the past few weeks,
Detective Gestur Palmason
has been chasing down leads
and pursuing suspects.
He's on the hunt for COVID-19,
where he and dozens
of other detectives
are tracking every single case
of coronavirus in the country.
-As quickly as we can,
we have to reach everyone
that might have been in contact
with someone who's positive
and try to stop them before they
get in contact with more people.
-They literally have detectives
tracking down cases.
Not only is that
an effective method
for containing the disease,
it's also a great premise
for a Netflix crime drama
starring Kenneth Branagh
as Detective Gestur Palmason.
Hey, Kenneth, so excited to be
working with you.
Have you worked on
an Icelandic accent?
[ British accent ] I think I'll
just use my British accent.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah, but,
no, it takes place in Iceland,
so everyone will have
an Icelandic accent.
[ British accent ]
No, I think everyone else
should be British, too.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah, but
Kenneth, won't that be weird?
[ British accent ]
I'm sorry, friend.
Those are the Kenny Branagh
rules.
[ Normal voice ]
And that was an extended bit
for people who have seen
BBC's production
of the Swedish crime drama
"Wallander."
Hey, the attic shows
are going to have
some deep cuts, everybody.
Thems the rules.
One of the biggest takeaways
of Iceland's approach
is that by aggressively testing
everyone,
they've been able to avoid
having to lock down
their entire country
the way we've had to.
-It's very important to test
very aggressively.
We put those who test positive
in isolation.
And we do contact tracing
very aggressively, also.
We put all contacts
in quarantine.
And it's interesting that
more than half of those
who we are diagnosing now
are actually in quarantine
when they're diagnosed,
which means that our policy
of quarantine is probably
very effective
in minimizing the epidemic.
-This has allowed authorities
here to delay the closure
of bars and restaurants like
in many other major cities.
Some stores remain open.
People still walk the streets
and explore the great outdoors.
-They still get to go outside.
And their outside is awesome.
They have lagoons and volcanoes.
The closest thing we have
to a lagoon here in the U.S.
is Disney's Typhoon Lagoon,
and that thing is germ city.
They should call it
Typhoid Lagoon.
So in Iceland,
they get to go outside.
Meanwhile, in New York,
to go outside,
you have to wrap your head
in scarves
and swerve into the street
to keep a distance of six feet
from people on the sidewalk.
At this point, you're better off
just hitching a ride
on the back of a garbage truck.
New Yorkers aren't used
to avoiding people.
They're used to bumping into
people.
That's why the line
in "Midnight Cowboy"
was, "Hey, I'm walking here!"
not, "Hey,
I'm trying to maintain
a safe distance of at least
six feet here!"
And then there's South Korea,
which had its first case
on the exact same day
that we had our first case.
They deployed massive
nationwide testing
to track and contain
the spread of the disease.
As Fox News found out
on Wednesday,
when they invited a doctor on
who was much more critical
of the Trump administration than
they were probably expecting.
-Now, what we hear every night
is that the tests,
that there are millions of tests
available.
And yet, we don't have that
pinprick blood test you can get,
you know, at your local doctor
and know in 15 minutes.
But they're working on it.
-Yeah, they're working on it.
They should have been working
on it for months.
So the fact is we knew about
this from the WHO when?
December 31st, 2019.
So last year,
we knew about this.
We needed this months ago.
You look at Korea, Korea --
South Korea and the U.S.
had their first official
confirmed case
on the same date --
January 19th.
Let me say this --
You look at what South Korea did
and what we did.
Their population
is 1/6 of ours.
Look at the cases they have.
Look at the mortality they have.
It's a trifle compared to what
we're dealing with right now.
Because we've had a very weak
response
and they had a really strong
response.
-Oh, man. Fox news viewers never
hear that kind of real talk.
You asked the wrong doctor.
That's like asking your
weird Uncle if Santa's real.
[ Inhales sharply ]
Not only is he not real,
he's just a construct
of a consumeristic system
designed to melt your brains
before you learn to think
for yourself.
Anyway -- ho, ho, ho.
I got you some scratchers.
Also, I love how long
he shakes his head
while she's repeating
Trump's talking points.
They should put that guy
in a box on the screen
during all of Trump's
press briefings.
-This is a flu.
This is like a flu.
-So South Korea's
contained the outbreak
with aggressive testing.
Meanwhile, here in the U.S.,
our president said in a
conference call with governors,
he hadn't even heard about
problems with testing.
-Do you have any system
in place that you feel
can adequately identify cases
and isolate them
and contact trace them?
Are there capabilities
and resources there
that's not something you can
do given with what you have?
-Dr. Fauci, we are trying to do
contact tracing.
But literally,
we are one day away
if we don't get test kits
from the CDC
that we wouldn't be able
to do testing in Montana.
We just don't have enough
supplies to do the testing.
-Tony, you can answer
if you want,
but I haven't heard about
testing in weeks.
I haven't heard about testing
being a problem.
-If you haven't heard about
testing being a problem,
then you need to get tested
to see if you have a problem
like a hearing test
or a vision test.
I mean, maybe Trump just can't
read his briefings. Look at him.
Whenever he reads off
a teleprompter,
he looks like he just finished
15 rounds with Apollo Creed.
And now that we've failed
at testing,
we have to massively ramp up
hospital capacity,
something the Trump
administration
is also failing at.
For example,
hospitals desperately need
life-saving ventilators.
And yet the president doesn't
even know what they're called.
-We sent thousands of generators
to New York.
The people in New York never
distributed the generators.
-Ventilators!
They're called ventilators!
Having this guy in charge
is like sending your grandpa
to GameStop to pick up
video games.
[ Elderly voice ]
I need the new Line of Duty
for the X-Station Play-Box.
[ Normal voice ] Also,
now is not the time
to send your grandpa
to GameStop, you coward.
Just go, grandpa.
You'll be safe.
Trump doesn't even know
what ventilators are called.
[ As Trump ] Here are
the emergency ventriloquists
you guys asked for.
[ Normal voice ] Oh, actually,
we said ventilators.
[ As Trump ] I told you he said
ventilators, you dummy.
[ High-pitched ]
"I'm not the dummy.
You're the dummy!
[ Lower-pitched ] Why, I oughta!
[ Normal voice ] Now, Trump
should have used his powers
under the Defense Production Act
to order companies
to make ventilators weeks ago,
but he's only done it once
during this pandemic,
even though his administration
has apparently used it
repeatedly before this.
"The New York Times" reported
that the Defense Production Act
has been invoked
hundreds of thousands of times
in the Trump years.
But with the pandemic,
the president sees it
as a "Break the Glass"
last resort.
Hey, man.
It's time to break the glass.
It was time to break the glass
weeks ago.
Of course, knowing Trump,
if he does have one of those
"Break glass in case
of emergency" boxes
in the White House, it's
probably not a fire alarm,
But, you know, like an emergency
chicken wing.
And they probably have hundreds
of them on the wall
because he breaks one
every five minutes.
Sir, if you want a chicken wing,
you can order it from the chef.
[ As Trump ] I didn't have time.
It was an emergency.
[ Normal voice ]
So now we have a situation
where states are begging
for life-saving ventilators,
and the Trump team
is in disarray.
The Pentagon says it still
hasn't sent ventilators
because it hasn't been told
where to send them.
And the "New York Times"
reported
that thousands of ventilators
in the stockpile don't work
because the government
let the contract
to maintain the stockpile
lapse last summer.
So now governors are literally
outbidding each other
on the open market and dealing
with shady middlemen
and price gouging to buy
ventilators
wherever they can get them.
-Every state
does its own purchasing.
So New York is purchasing.
California's purchasing.
Illinois is purchasing.
We're all trying to buy
the same commodity --
Literally the same exact item.
So you have 50 states competing
to buy the same item.
We all wind up
bidding up each other
and competing against each other
where you now literally
will have a company
call you up and say, "Well,
California just outbid you."
It's like being on eBay
with 50 other states
bidding on a ventilator.
-It's the Wild West.
And these are crazy markets,
and you get a lot of bad actors.
-It's more like surge pricing
on Uber,
only at the last moment,
the car drives away
because somebody has outbid you.
-That's right.
Governors are comparing
buying life-saving ventilators
for a pandemic to surge pricing.
This is capitalism
at its absolute worst.
While Trump waits for the market
to decide,
people are literally
going to die
and states are getting
ripped off.
Like they're frying to call
an Uber in the rain in Midtown
after a Broadway show.
And even worse, the ventilators
come with a driver
who won't stop trying to make
a conversation
even though you're very clearly
trying to take a nap.
And you'll never guess who's in
charge of this [bleep] show --
The guy Slender Man
has nightmares about --
Jared Kushner.
That's right. The real Slim
Shady has been put in charge
of the ventilator problem.
And after New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo said publicly
that his state needed 30,000
more ventilators,
apparently Kushner pushed back.
Kushner told people that Cuomo
is being an alarmist.
"I have all this this data
about ICU capacity.
I'm doing my own projections,
and I've gotten a lot smarter
about this.
New York doesn't need
all the ventilators.
Oh, oh, you're doing
your own projections?
Did your parents just buy you
a TI-84?
You're not qualified
to do anything,
let alone tell New York
how many ventilators they need.
You're a nepotism case,
and you only got
the White House job
because you married
into the family
and because the security guards
believed your fake I.D.
"You are good to go, Mr. Cowboy.
And, hey, give that virus
hell for us."
I hope when the time
for accountability comes,
we can all remember that it
didn't have to be like this.
Other countries responded
to this pandemic with competence
and they avoided the worst.
Now we're bracing for
an unimaginable tragedy.
And as we speak, the president
is leaving besieged states
and hospitals to fend
for themselves,
putting lives at risk.
But hey, at least...
-Most people have scarves.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.